you guys want to do a good deed this
weekend just stay home and watch Captain
America the Winter Soldier on blu-ray
you'll feel much better about yourself
trust me no good deed stars Idris Elba
and taraji P Henson really tried with
that name probably screwed it up don't
give a crap in this movie inter sailboat
plays a guy who really hates women he
just has this thing about women they
enrage him he wants to beat them up and
even kill him and he's done it many
times in the past and for one reason or
another he ends up on the doorstep of a
mother who's caring for two children
while her husband is away he acts like
he needs a place to stay and since she's
nice she lets him in her house and the
majority of this movie is him just
creeping her out and for some reason
she's okay with it for a large majority
of the runtime because if she starts to
act like there's a problem the movies
gonna end a lot shorter than it should
be for a feature-length runtime no good
deed really wasn't very good at all
it's horrible actually the thing about
no good deed is that it has two
fantastic performances in all honesty
injures elbows one of my favorite actors
and he sells this role he elevates the
idiotic cliched material he really does
and taraji P Henson is also really good
in this movie these are two really good
performances and it makes the movie look
better than it actually is it's like the
director in this movie had himself on
standard mode it's like if you had
standard and then high-energy and then
holy crap Martin Scorsese mode it was
like he was just on standard mode he
gets shots they look okay but he doesn't
really do anything different or original
there's no flair to his style in this
movie and the writing is so bad I mean
there are certain things that characters
do and you're like why are you doing
that who invites a guy into their house
in the middle of the night and just goes
like yeah you can walk around all here's
my kids look oh yeah oh you're crazy
until she finally decides to fight back
but it takes forever because this is a
movie that's literally just about a guy
in a house being weird that's it
so they can't really go anywhere with
any of these characters beyond the
average they're gonna run around they're
gonna hide in the closet they're gonna
run around again maybe somebody will get
hit in the face they're gonna hide in
the closet again it's just like there
are so many different things that could
be done
with a plot like this and none of them
are done because it just goes for the
standard mode you know this movie
reminded me of a movie that came out in
2001 with John Travolta and Vince Vaughn
and teri polo called domestic
disturbance do you guys ever see that
movie it's a very similar movie in
regards to certain things it's just like
it's just a domestic dispute of some
kind and it just yeah there's nothing
about it it's really that interesting
and it's done without any Flair the
other one had Vince Vaughn know so
that's kind of funny
as I said interest Elba is a fantastic
actor he is great in this movie even
though the script is really dumb and
taraji P Henson is also really good it's
just that the characters don't make any
sense I mean one of the biggest glaring
errors that really bugged me was that
she's like oh yeah I'm like a homicide
person like I used to do like homicide
cases and stuff and I've seen a lot of
stuff in my life and there's like a
maniac killer right in front of her and
she's completely oblivious to it all
maybe that's why she's not a homicide
lawyer anymore
because she really sucked at her job I'm
gonna give no good deed a d-plus
not really a good movie just skip it
don't worry about it I wish it could
have been better because I love those
actors they both did a great job but
other than that no guys thank you so
much as always for watching my reviews I
really appreciate it and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]